Du
Hast gelernt, wie man Adobe Illustrator bedient und du
hast dich mit den Grundfunktionen des Programmes vertraut
gemacht.
Du kannst jetzt Dateien anlegen und speichern und dich
innerhalb des Programmes orientieren.
Du kennst auch schon einige Bedienfelder wie zum Beispiel
Eigenschaften oder Ebenen Du hast
verschiedene Werkzeuge kennengelernt und kannst
diese bedienen.
Das sind zum einen die Auswahlwerkzeuge, die Zeichenfeder,
das Rechteck und das Linienwerkzeug,
Spiegeln und auch die Lupe.
Du hast gelernt, wie man Formen und Linien verändert,
spiegelt oder auch anordnet.
Außerdem hast du gelernt,
mit Ebenen zu arbeiten und diese auch sinnvoll anzuwenden.
Du kannst Bilder importieren und platzieren.
Du kannst erste technische Zeichnung erstellen und
beschriften.
Diese Grundlagen kannst du jetzt üben und zum Beispiel
verschiedene Rockformen erstellen.
Als nächsten Kurs empfehle ich dir technische Zeichnungen
für Oberteile.
Parallel zu diesem Kurs empfehle ich dir alle
Grundlagenkurse für den Rockgrundschnitt und den Modellrock
und außerdem die entsprechenden Kurse für die Fertigung.
Ich hoffe es hat dir Spaß gemacht und wir sehen uns in einem
unserer nächsten Kurse wieder.